a march on capitol hill demanding the
guns that killed their loved ones are
banned
gloria cesares is here she wants you to
remember her daughter jackie killed at
her school in uvalde texas she was funky
she was sassy she sometimes had that
little attitude that no she knew she
believed in something that's what she
was going to fight for
she can now see for herself how police
responded to her daughter being shot
media outlets releasing four minutes of
security camera footage
they edited out the sounds of the
children screaming
you can clearly see police arrive two
minutes after the shooting started a few
approach the classroom door
but run away less than a minute later
after shots are fired
as the minutes tick by the shooting
continues
the police stand and watch one gets hand
sanitizer
eventually a small army of police arrive
with bulletproof shields body armor and
automatic weapons they rush in and kill
the gunman after 75 minutes of waiting
one of the way this videotape is going
to change the debate is republicans
after mass shootings often say what's
needed for a bad guy with a gun is a
good guy with a gun that was obviously
not the case in uvalde
cesares is enraged the world can see
this video before she could she doesn't
know that she'll ever watch it but she
will live with the unbearable question
of what her daughter was experiencing
for these 75 minutes shot
but alive
i don't know when she was shot i think
it was at the beginning but
[Music]
she survived 77 minutes
she didn't die at that school she died
at the hospital
so i don't know
i don't know
i don't know but there's a possibility
if they have breached that room my
daughter might have might have survived
along with there's
quite a bit of others that had
non-threatening
injuries and just bled to death
there is one more thing she would like
the world to know about her
nine-year-old little girl jackie had
a heart of gold
she
was always
looking to help somebody else she always
thought of others before herself
equality apparently not on display here
patty culhane al jazeera washington